on Prime crime I ran outside and called
the police and
our nightmare started a teen girl
vanishes in the night all your focus on
is finding your daughter you know you
just want to find your kid and evil may
be right around the corner you just wish
that someone had recognized that they
had a ticking time bomb in their midst
thank you
[Music]
hi there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases
we cover some truly heinous acts here on
the show and our next story is really no
different
but what makes this one especially
chilling is The Who and the why
it was a very unusual day for us because
Stacy and I as most parents were
typically up early we were sworn to stay
into our room because Tristan and Sophia
were going to make breakfast for Stacy
for Mother's Day
Mother's Day 2021 St John's Florida what
should be a happy time of celebration
for the bailly family becomes a day of
Terror I walked out and Sophia was
making breakfast by herself and I was
like where's Tristan she's like she's
still sleeping and then my son came
downstairs
I asked him to go upstairs and to wake
up Tristan for breakfast he came back
then he is like Mom listen I know I'm
blind but I didn't see her up there and
then it
instantaneously hit me sheer panic
on Saturday Tristan had a normal family
day she went to dinner with her family
she visited one of her sisters that
night unbeknownst to the family she had
sort of made some loose plans to hang
out with friends later that night
but thirteen-year-old Tristan Bailey
never came home
they ran upstairs and went to her room
and she wasn't there I went to the
bathroom I went to our TV room upstairs
she wasn't there
everyone just started running to every
single room I ran outside and called the
police and
our nightmare started
that sort of started the timeline of law
enforcement getting involved and started
as a missing child investigation so many
times with those types of calls
especially with a teenager a lot of
times it's a runaway so they are treated
serious until it's deemed that they
aren't
authorities now need to piece together
what Tristan was doing before she
disappeared we had a great dinner with
my son Tristan and Sophia and our
granddaughter and then we left dinner
and
went to see Alexis and her new kittens I
remember
Tristan immediately ran into the kitten
room she loves any kind of animals we
went home and I actually was sitting at
our dining room table falling asleep and
the three of them Tegan and Sophie and
Tristan were up and just saying I love
you and going to bed
investigators learned that Tristan left
the house after FaceTiming with someone
her family didn't know that she had left
the house and she went off with a boy
she went out and went over to a friend's
house by the name of Trey and his friend
Aidan fucci was there and she hung out
at Trey's house a little bit that night
it soon becomes clear that Tristan
leaving her house would have horrifying
consequences
it's hard can you tell me what's going
on today so I heard there was a missing
girl we see the whole neighborhood's
been a bus people
been looking for sheriffs he's been
around helicopters flying my wife had
mentioned maybe checking in the woods
over here along the end of the
cul-de-sac
and at the pond into the property next
to us a neighbor who lived in the
community was going to go out for a run
and he knew you know there was a missing
child his wife had mentioned to him you
know check the woods at the end of the
cul-de-sac kids would go back there and
use it for different things hang out
things like that I finished my run and I
walked around through the woods and I
just a last sweep and when I came out of
the fence at the southern end of the
pond I saw a dead girl there as soon as
I saw her I stopped and called 9-1-1
unfortunately when she was found it was
very clear it was a it was a homicide at
that point we just knew we had a girl
that was you know we didn't know the
full extent at all of the number of stab
wounds but it was pretty clear she was
stabbed Tristan was stabbed 114 times
most of the wounds were defensive wounds
so she put up a fight she fought back
it was a bloody awful crime scene
there wasn't a lot in the scene
essentially and it was her and some of
her personal items and affects her vape
and her cell phone and jewelry and I
think some money there on the ground no
murder weapon or anything right there
but just her you know laying in the
woods I actually was in the front yard
and
I had a lot of my friends surrounding me
but I remember the police walking up to
me and telling me that I needed to go
inside with them
it begged him not to take me inside
I remember collapsing in my front yard
pleading for them not to tell me
what I knew was coming
they shared the news
there's nothing
that's more devastating than that
Tristan came from a close-knit family
she was one of five siblings and with
two loving parents and they called
themselves the Bailey seven Tristan was
a 13 year old probably average middle
school girl she was a very outgoing
bubbly girl she was described by
everybody I talked to as everyone's
friend
Tristan was just completely and totally
vibrant as a daughter she was absolutely
phenomenal our family is so diverse in
what their interests were and she was
the Common Thread that went throughout
she was just
somebody that was a bundle of energy yet
also a bundle of love
she was an excellent student was
actually just talking about maybe going
on and becoming a doctor she was
starting to get some career aspirations
along that path Tristan was a very
active competitive cheerleader
cheerleading was her first kind of love
the question is who could have done this
to Tristan Bailey how long you've known
Tristan I have a group of friends which
is me Aiden and his girlfriend Sophie
we're all pretty close
Tristan I would hang out with her more
alone or with like if I had somebody
staying the night she'd come over and
he'd be the three of us you start
looking at anybody in her life it was
very early through her friends that
they're providing like anyone that they
know that she potentially would have
snuck out to be with during your
conversations with her has she talked
recently about wanting to run away
she said that one time after she got
caught by her sister she's like oh my
God I want to run away she got caught by
her sister like sneaking out one of
those friends is 14 year old Trey who
went to school with Tristan he and
another boy from school 14 year old
Aiden fucci were believed to be the last
ones with Tristan the night she
disappeared
Trey was Aidan Fuji's best friend Aiden
was our classmate of Tristan's and they
probably knew of each other Trey knew
Tristan and Aiden had seen her with him
when did you first meet Aiden and start
to be friends with them I've known Aiden
for about a year we became friends
within the first five minutes
can you describe Aiden's attitude his
personality his demeanor didn't care
about anything he was a really big
pothead
he was really chill Aiden had a history
of documented behavioral issues some
academic issues we found out through
talking to his friends that there was a
lot of drug use that he was into he had
just come to our school it was not a
name that we ever heard
in her circle of friends and they only
had one class together according to the
teachers they didn't even speak to each
other in class
that particular night Aiden wanted her
to come over he didn't even have her
contact information so he got the
information from Trey hey I want to
invite that girl Tristan over and then
did
what all happened Saturday night
Saturday night Aiden came over around
eight after he got done hanging out with
Sophie so me and him were outside and
then I was like hey do you want to Snug
him over and he was just like I don't
care shoulder so I called her invited
her over they all live in the same
neighborhood Tristan left her home
unbeknownst to her family and went over
to Trey's house her sister caught her
sneaking out that night
and then she got there she was freaking
out she was like oh my God she caught me
she's gonna tell my parents and then
ain't just like you're good you're fine
nothing's gonna happen and then later
that evening Trey wanted to go to bed
and so he kicked them out of the house I
told him to leave they left and then I
just went back to sleep do you know
about what time Aiden and Tristan left
between 1 and 110 did they say anything
about where they were going to go after
they left I just told them to leave and
then rolled back over and heard the door
open and they both left
what's the next thing that happened
that night he never texted me never
called me
investigators need to answer the burning
question could Trey or Aiden be involved
in what happened to this young
cheerleader when we found out who it was
It was a
state of disbelief just absolute
disbelief
[Music]
so you don't want to talk to us what
happened but I can't even tell y'all
anymore
it's Mother's Day weekend 2021 St John's
Florida police are investigating The
Disappearance of 13-year-old Tristan
Bailey who never came home after hanging
out with friends late Saturday night her
body is located the next day near a pond
in a wooded area adjacent to the
neighborhood where she lived she had
been stabbed a total of 114 times police
begin their investigation by speaking
with the friend she was believed to be
with the night she disappeared Tristan's
friend Trey shed some light on that
Sunday morning spoke of around nine I
thought Hayden was home Tristan was home
I called Aiden and that was a site what
happened last night he just said he
dropped her off at the front of her
neighborhood and he went home one person
was checked out with them pretty early
that morning I believe 10 or 11 A.M they
were some of the first names if not the
first I was like the cops are on the way
to your house I was just like they were
coming to talk to you that's going to
like a little bit of panic
into space just a little bit police
realize they need to speak with Aiden
maybe he can shed some light on what
happened
are you willing to kind of give me a
statement about what's going on yeah so
we we're at Trey's house and I stayed
there until probably like 1 50 a.m and
then I was really late to be home so I
just had to leave or else my mom would
like seriously just kill me he had
changed his story from you know I didn't
see her to I saw her and walked her home
basically and then changed it to well we
got in an argument and I pushed her down
instead of walking home and then next
like where that brick wall starts up
there okay is where like she touched me
and I like pushed her off me real hard
and then I just kind of walked away to
anger as the day went on and the night
went on we found more and more video
surveillance and you could actually
start following them through the
neighborhood and so then we knew he was
the last one with her a short period of
time later
Aiden was caught running on video by
himself holding his shoes and there was
no Tristan in the video
when you have a lot of the witnesses a
lot of the people involved and they're
minors it's very easy for what somebody
heard and what something goes through as
a rumor versus the truth to diverge
police detain Aiden and Trey in the back
of a cruiser and that's when Aiden does
something very concerning eventually
they all pull up in the front of the
house and they move me into the squad
car with Aiden he was like let's make
memories like you make a Snapchat memory
and you save it so we remember whenever
like all this happened it's in a cop car
cuz
I'm tripping dude it's all right
Aiden was put in the back of a police
car to be questioned and posted on
Snapchat real self-serving picture of
him like defiant
and pretending that he didn't know
anything about this
we're having fun yep
Tristan what's up guys interested if you
walk out the dam when you see this in a
month
I made one and I was just like Tristan
whenever you do come back when they find
you I'm gonna be so mad at you I had to
sit in the back of a cop car for like 30
minutes I didn't know anything happen
his friends started messaging him one
friend messaged him that you know
why she went missing that you know what
happened here were there any other
conversations that you had with Aiden he
made a joke about us being in prison
and I was like that's not funny he was
like wouldn't it be funny like we both
went the same prison and I was like no
not really looking at his behavior it
just felt downright
sadistic disgusting the way that
he behaved
disbelief I think to know that somebody
could be so cold and I I just don't even
have words for it
it was it was hard to watch that let me
see Folk
thank you
take his swim team for now
we're gonna be holding onto your phones
all right buddy
hey Siri
tag is a dream girl they took my phone
I'm using Siri and I love you bye
hey Siri
Texas dream Barrel I can't see your text
the phone's in the front seat I'm
talking through the glass
hey Siri text dream girl please stick
with me through this
just had a complete and total arrogance
just a lack of care of human life
what's this verse is it holding room
once he's brought into the station Aiden
stops talking to authorities but when
his parents come into the room their
recorded conversation reveals a lot more
you know they found this girl right
where in our neighborhood down our Main
Street
is she good no she's not she's dead
parents asked to see him so he was
placed in a room with them and they just
started you know asking questions this
is very important
it's all on you right now
really my problem
last one seen with her so right now it's
a lot of it's facing you right now son
so however you talk you breathe you
think
then you respond
this is very serious Aiden you can't act
like I don't know you know I think it
gave a lot of insight into his character
and who he is his whole attitude
was very nonchalant you're 14 years old
and this is your classmate and your
friend and you were with her last night
did you kiss or do anything with this
girl be honest as you can
yeah I kissed her
any further
um
so your DNA's gonna be on her his story
was that they got to this particular
intersection and they had kissed and
then she grabbed his private part and he
pushed her down
she pushed her down and then you walked
away we shouldn't be talking
you walked away you came straight home
you didn't turn back around see what you
want
did they ever seen why it took you so
long to get home
so walk around
by yourself
did you just walk really slow home
she hit her head but I just left her
there and claimed to have just walked
home after that he doesn't get home
until two hours later
what was he doing in those two hours as
well he said he was just walking around
do you know if this girl picked up
dealer
you think she got picked up by him yeah
Aiden introduced that into the mix that
there was some person that sold and it
wasn't even necessarily her I mean he
said that that was her dealer she said
she wouldn't come home
she said she's gonna find somebody left
her there walking like you think she got
picked up after that she just kept
walking probably here is this model
young person who is beloved in her
community who has a tight-knit family
who is a great student a cheerleader and
somehow she disappears
and goes to a drug dealer's house didn't
make any sense did you see this 20 year
old kid
we didn't get in his car
I just heard about him that night I'll
knock her about it many times
Aiden says he doesn't know anything
about Tristan's murder when we return
can anyone get him to talk he didn't do
nothing right
it's a hell of a bad time bad spot
leaving a 13 year old girl by herself in
the middle of the streets at three
o'clock in the morning it's not smart
[Music]
this is very excited
it's very serious this is no joke this
is your whole life your whole life
and hers and ours and your brothers and
sisters
Mother's Day weekend 2021 St John's
Florida authorities set their sights on
14 year old Aiden fucci in the Savage
stabbing of one of his classmates
Tristan Bailey a 13 year old girl found
dead in the woods near the neighborhood
in which the two teens lived Aiden is
questioned several times by police
particularly since surveillance footage
captures fucci and Bailey walking
together late in the evening before
she's killed but when he's brought into
the police station the only people he's
talking to are his parents
and then something else caught
investigators attention
you saw your uh your shoes were off on
the camera blow your shoes off
get on February
unless she's giving me blisters
I'm gonna go home and get your clothes
I'm up close the clothes you're wearing
maybe another one that's closer
I think ultimately what was important
from that interaction with his mostly
his mom was he admitted one thing she
basically asked him what he was wearing
when he came home
you want khakis or Philippines
sure enough
and we looked on the camera
right
he said jeans she's trying to insinuate
to him that no you're wearing khakis
when you look back at our surveillance
video all the daytime video it's very
clear he's wearing jeans and then Trey
told us he left the house in jeans
they're gonna keep them you're right
I said I know of you
unless you know any other thing I don't
know
nothing to worry about her
Aiden's parents wanted to know the truth
from Aiden but they didn't want law
enforcement to know the truth be not
scared
oh really not really I'm a little scared
if you didn't do nothing to be worried
about they were telling Aiden in the
interrogation room to find a story and
stick with it they were more concerned
about their son's ability to get away
with it than taking responsibility I
still see why you kissed her analysis
and she grabbed you and you pushed her
did I find your story and stay tuned
yeah and I like all that squishing back
and forth stuff
police dig even deeper into Aiden he may
be suspicious but could this 14 year old
be a killer authorities speak with his
girlfriend
it was really
tell me his mom would tell him
tell him disappointment
he felt neglected by her that he felt
neglected by both of his parents
that he was the least favorite in his
family
Sophie was the girlfriend of Aiden Fuji
at the time she's one of the ones that
told us all of his thoughts and desires
she was probably one of the main people
he confided in he
told me that sometimes his dad would
hidden
and his dad never really let him show
emotions he feels worthless perhaps
suicidal that he was having thoughts in
his head to commit some sort of violence
he
issues
he told me that
that he hated doing things that he
didn't mean to do when he got angry
have you ever seen Aiden get violent
with anybody
yes so if he knew that Aiden was deeply
troubled but she never believed that he
would actually commit such a horrific
act against himself or others he was
into satanic evil violent type of
drawings he would do them himself he
would ask other friends to draw them for
him they didn't told me that
he
had voices in in his head that told him
those things
that I told him
that he was
worthless and a disappointment someone
who is Disturbed enough to have satanic
drawings and other ways that he was
lashing out for help but at that point
there was similarly no one who could
help him
did Aiden ever discuss anything to you
that would make you think he wanted to
try to use a knife on somebody didn't
talk
we always teach people if you see
something say something but when you're
a young person and another person is
lashing out verbally you sometimes just
talk up to braggadocia that he's just
talking smack Aiden and I had a dark
sense of humor and I never
chicken
seriously he talked about
wanting to kill me
sometimes he would take his knife and
pretend to stab me with it
did you ever hear Aiden discuss having a
certain plan that he wanted to carry out
did he ever discuss in detail like this
is how I would do something or this is
what I want to do
yeah again the difficult part of it is
there were people who knew
what he was contemplating and what he
was planning that's one thing that kept
coming out is
we didn't think he was being for real
but that's not even funny in this case
it was real
he didn't just talk it he did it he said
that he would just walk at night and
find like a random person walking to and
just drag them in the woods and stab
them he said I should expect it within
the month and when was that that he said
this
I think this month that's one reason why
investigators were able to focus on
Aiden because of the words he said which
now made sense
authorities are gathering evidence that
suggests Aiden fucci may be Tristan
Bailey's killer but is any of this
enough to actually charge him with
Murder coming up authorities make a
haunting Discovery his girlfriend zofi
told me that he's talked about stabbing
people killing people then this happens
[Music]
it's not like him what's not like him
to kill someone
it's May 2021 and police are
investigating The Disappearance and
death of 13-year-old Tristan Bailey in
St John's Florida the young teen was
found stabbed to death on Mother's Day
their Prime Suspect is Tristan's
classmate 14 year old Aiden fucci who
officials say was the last person seen
with her on doorbell and surveillance
camera footage around the neighborhood
they lived in investigators speak with
several of Tristan's friends and there's
one more shocking connection between the
young cheerleaders murder and Aiden
fucci did Aiden carry any personal items
on him Aiden kept knives for protection
he always had a knife on him if he
wasn't at school we found out he was
very obsessed with knives he had two in
particular that he had named
he called
one picker and then called that one
poker
they look like this
yeah that's the same name the murder
weapon was found in the pond right
nearby
and the tip of that knife was found in
Tristan's head
everything investigators have learned
leads to a search of the Fuji's home we
located shoes that were hidden that has
a positive for blood a shirt of his
and a pair of jeans and a hamper that
were dampened and a lot of those items
dusted positive for blood the drain trap
in his bathroom sink we were able to get
her DNA on that night even though it had
been in water for a period of time the
evidence was pretty overwhelming that he
was lying all along she didn't just
disappear
she didn't just run to some drug
dealer's house never to be seen again he
was directly involved with her death
the Saint John's Sheriff's Office they
realized there was no sleep going on in
our house there was Panic going on and
we were also in fear not knowing how
this could happen Aiden fucci is
arrested and charged with murder and due
to the brutality of the crime he's set
to be tried as an adult facing 40 years
to life in prison they showed up at our
door and
3 40 in the morning and he told us that
they had him it was one of the first of
many shifts with all all of a sudden
that knowing we just needed to focus on
our grieving it's horrific seeing a
young child like that killed right
number one and then to think that
another child could have done it was
awful
yet Fuji wasn't the only one who faced
charges from their own home surveillance
system we discovered that Crystal went
up to his room and located a pair of
jeans and a hamper that she felt had
blood on them and then you see where she
is taking them into a bathroom and
clearly washing them in a sink what that
was is tampering with evidence and we
chose to charge her if you want to know
why someone can become Aidan Fuji where
it's a cry for help just look to the
mother
who then enabled him who quickly tried
to wash away the blood on his jeans the
fact that they had cameras meant that
there was more evidence against Aiden
and evidence against the mother
seeing what she saw
on his jeans and knowing
that my child was missing and he was the
last one seen with her
I just have no words for it nearly two
years after Tristan Bailey's murder
Aidan fucci is set to go on trial
however as jury selection is about to
begin he makes a life-changing move
that morning we were set to pick a jury
but it's 9 9 30. I'm sitting back in
Chambers we still have no idea whether
it's happening or not your honor on
behalf of Aidan Fuji we enter a change
of plea at this time
Mr Fuji is it your desire to enter a
plea of guilty one count of first-degree
murder yes sir part of me was shocked I
knew there would still be a lengthy
sentencing hearing because he was a
juvenile but you're happy that the
family doesn't have to go through a
trial there was a lot of people coming
up to us with a feeling that we would
have a great sense of relief
we had already gone through and prepared
for all the potentially horrific themes
that could come up
so some of the things that we could have
been spared we were never spared with
the death penalty off the table because
fucci was a juvenile now the question is
how long would he spend in prison what
he tried to do was to plead guilty and
then hope that his guilty plea and his
sudden expression of remorse
would convince the judge to sentence him
to something less than life in prison
everybody knows the saying that pictures
are worth a thousand words I know you
will never
forget those photos there were 114
salads
49 of those were defensive
she was fighting
there will be juveniles
that will deserve a life sentence and
Aidan Fuji is one of those that was sort
of a goal to point out and put on
evidence of why this murder he is a
juvenile but this murder is very very
different it was not impetuous and he
needs to be locked up for as long as
possible to protect all of society
the behavior is so unusual in this case
for a 14 and a half year old it's hard
to know if immaturity played any role
whatsoever he's a really unique person I
would say in a bad way he's he's
demonstrating some things that I think
are extremely clinically concerning that
we usually do not see in youth
prognosis is poor for rehabilitation
when it comes to juvenile cases in
Florida if you're going to give someone
life in prison the judge has to make an
individualized determination based on
The Young Person's upbringing and the
facts and circumstances of his life we
can't go backwards in time we can't undo
the action the only thing that we can do
today
is answer the question of a sentence
and that's whether Aiden would be
sentenced to life through prison or 40
years
40 years is not a light sentence it is
not an easy sentence
it still is punishment
I think our biggest hurdle if we had one
was honestly probably his age he was not
mentally well
he was not mature for his age
children do not make sound decisions or
wise decisions nothing in this offense
points to maturity you have to jump
through hoops in a juvenile case to get
someone life in prison that you don't
have to jump through in an adult case
part of what Dr pritchard's relying on
is the actions in terms of 114 stab
wounds in his opinion that shows
premeditation how do you disagree with
that I don't understand it you mean in
Fuji sat down someplace and said I'm
going to stab this girl 114 times is
that what's being said
I don't see how you can say anything
about his impetuosity at the time of the
offense without making assumptions about
what's going on in his State of Mind in
his head I think that given
mentorship programs counseling people
reaching out to him
that there's a likelihood that he could
be rehabilitated
and for arguably the first time Aiden
showed some emotion when his grandmother
spoke I wish I could change when it
happened and um
we pray for you every day
I hope that you find peace somewhere in
and we lost a child too it was uh a lot
of conflicting emotions
when she got up on that stand
my heart hurt for her is that the boy
you knew
he's not the boy that I knew I don't
know what happened I mean he's always
been good and happy
I'm so sorry
he's a good family
we don't condone what happened and uh
we're very sorry for your loss
it was the first time that we had heard
from anybody immediately closely
connected
any type of emotion remorse or anything
so
it went a long way for us it also just
points out the fact that when you have
these people committing these crimes
they destroy multiple families
and they destroy their own family as
well
in his own words Fuji actually wrote an
apology letter to Tristan's family we
were given it in the middle of
sentencing he wrote it it looks like an
apology letter it's very simple it's not
very in-depth you know in the end I
think he's probably sorry
he got caught
the letter said in part quote I'm sorry
that you didn't get to know her that
long I know my apology will not fix
anything or bring her back but I hope it
helps in some way
it struck me as odd that what Aiden
apologized for was us not having more
time with her
and and still didn't hit me that he was
really truly sorry for killing her maybe
I'm jaded from being a prosecutor but I
don't believe a word someone like Aiden
Fuji says I mean now he's a morsel but
only after he faces life in prison it's
these deathbed conversions that you see
from people when they finally realize
they're going to pay a major price then
all of a sudden they express remorse
because they have to not because they
want to
before the sentence was handed down
Tristan's family was given an
opportunity to speak
114.
[Music]
this jar now holds 114 Stones one for
each of the 114 stab wins that my sister
had to endure it really almost put into
perspective I know for us sitting there
in that two minutes it took to drop
Stones
just how much she probably had to endure
I add this stone for the hope and belief
I had and people being good that died
the day that Aiden fucci murdered my
sister
you Aiden fucci
decided to overpower a five foot three
innocent 13 year old girl
how much more of a coward could you
possibly be
We Are Forever Tristan Bailey strong my
family's Victim Impact statements
were some of the most powerful I've if
not the most that I've ever seen even
13. you betrayed us all your deplorable
actions are unforgivable and I will pray
every day that you stay in prison for
the rest of your life your honor it
inferred to took the very life that I
brought into this world
please do not for one second think that
he could be rehabilitated at any point
he is beyond saving
[Music]
this crime had no motive
it was done for no other reason than to
satisfy
this defendant's internal desire to feel
what it was like to kill someone
there is only one appropriate sentence
in this case
Mr Fuji
having entered a plea of
guilty to the crime of first-degree
murder I adjudicate you guilty of the
pre-meded first degree murder of Tristan
Bailey
I sent you to life in prison eligible
for review of the sentence in 25 years
it was a maximum sentence that a judge
could have given a juvenile Aiden was
given life in prison hopefully he never
sees a lie today again
there was no motive
he just wanted to do it
and I think that's one of the most
difficult parts for us it's
there's nothing she did there was no
reason for the crime he just wanted to
kill somebody
it's hard to equate it with the feeling
a lot of people
ask us if there's any sense of closure
and
just given the age at the time
25 years it's going to be reviewed
as a family we're going to have to
endure what possibly could come up again
that may be the end for Aiden Fuji's
case but there was still the matter of
Aiden's mother Crystal Smith's charge of
tampering with evidence it's a third
degree felony so in Florida it's
punchable by up to five years we reached
a plea agreement with her Crystal was
given a month in jail and five years
probation it was a sentence that perhaps
wasn't as strong as some would like but
she pled guilty she took responsibility
for her despicable actions in this
tight-knit community She'll always be
known as the woman who raised
enabled and covered up for a monster
I think one of the most special moments
that I had with her was
the weekend before
sorry all done
the weekend before she passed away we
were
down in Orlando
at one of her cheer competitions
and all her friends are there she chose
to be with me instead of her friends
she was like Mom let's just go to Disney
let's just the two of us and
we did and we had the best day ever and
I will forever be grateful for
those those memories with her
the foundation is really
um it's where we have our energy and
it's going to give us a chance to put
passion into who Tristan was and what
she did but also what we've endured as a
family and hoping to make it so that
unfortunately when other families go
through
horrific experiences they don't have to
endure some of the same things we did
there is one positive that's come from
this absolutely awful case and that is
the passing of a new law in the State of
Florida something that was backed by the
Bailey family it is a law that now
limits the release of crime scene photos
involving a child a very tough issue for
Tristan's loved ones during this case
and while that may be a small win
Tristan's family and all of us may never
really understand why her life was taken
in such a brutal fashion by one of her
peers
but the Bailey family hopes that people
focus on the good that comes from
tragedy and on the impact that Tristan
made in her short 13 years of life
that's all we have for you here on this
episode of prime crime
until next time stay safe
[Music]